welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and today we're
traveling to the surface of the Sun
where you might get knighted with a
sword and lose your Impaler if you catch
Madrid today I'm going to take you frame
by frame through the penultimate episode
of season six of Rick and Morty to break
down all the details you might have
missed first let's talk about that
episode title our Rick and King mortar's
Mort is a play on Disney's 1995 a kid in
King Arthur's Court which itself is a
loose adaptation of Mark Twain's A
Connecticut Yankee in King Arthur's
Court actually both of these namesakes
have parallels with this very episode a
kid in King Arthur's Court is about a
baseball playing teen who sent back in
time and introduces Camelot to radical
90s technological Marvels like
rollerblades and CD players in
Connecticut Yankee a 19th century
engineer sent back in time to 6th
Century England and a scientific
know-how allows him to rival Merlin the
Wizard he even uses knowledge of a solar
eclipse to display his magic this
engineer's presence modernizes the past
while also creating dangerous conflict
with the Catholic Church which upholds
Arthurian society's status quo similar
to these stories this episode Morty's
introduction of modern science to an
Arthurian culture which eventually
modernizes it but also unravels the
fabric of society that keeps the peace
the episode opens on an asteroid where
Morty is excited to get in line for a
rare pop-up food joint obviously the
episode makes fun of the soulless art of
standing in line for hours waiting for a
pop-up but I definitely was one of the
500 people waiting in line to get an
overpriced t-shirt from the Rick mobile
a few years ago so is Pugsley so Rick
May hate lines but his marketing guy
loves him if we peep the signage on the
building that the line extends in front
of it looks to be written in a language
reminiscent of Star Wars is artibesh
alphabet when Morty kindly returns a
space sandwich to a pair of passing
Knights they admire his honesty kindness
and love of following rules and see that
he too could make a great member of
their Knighthood these soldiers are the
Knights of the Sun and their order
upholds the balance of the solar system
by protecting the solar scepter which
they believe the solar system revolves
around throughout history there have
been plenty of knights families and
countries that have used the Sun as part
of the heraldry but these Knights seem
to be in fired by the knights from Monty
Python and the Holy Grail and the
Warriors of sunlight from Dark Souls the
Warriors of sunlight are known for their
praise the son of moth but this Knight
briefly copies this blonde Knight is
actually voiced by British comedian and
star of Peep Show and that Michelin Webb
look David Mitchell his comedic partner
Robert Webb plays the redheaded night of
the sun seen later in the episode and
their Peep Show cast mate Matt King
plays the pooping night of the sun
towards the back half of the app sir
Helios offers Morty his sacred solar
sword as a reward for Morty picking up
his Fallen sandwich believing his
actions prove that he has a good heart
that you explain that they are Defenders
of Helios the center of the solar system
in Greek mythology Helios is a god of
and the embodiment of the sun who
iconically pulled his Chariot of fire
across the sky each day after some
pressure from the knights and alien
onlookers Morty agrees to take the sword
against Rick's advice the knights dub
Morty sir mortaniel so that he can have
a three-syllable nighty name which is
sort of unnecessary considering that
Morty's full name Mortimer is already
three syllables and Canon 90 already to
begin the transfer of title and power
over his success sir the Knight stabs
himself and His Life Energy returns to
the sun before Morty is teleported by
Frost style he tells Rick off calling
him a boring cranky drunk these words
seem to hit Rick's thawing post
pissmaster season 6 heart making him
exclaim ouch instead of retaliating
against Morty for ignoring his advice
like he's done in the past he decides to
fully support Morty including his
mistakes on the surface of the Sun sir
mortaniel is introduced to the Knights
of the Sun and announced to Sir helios's
successor one night looks like he was
modeled after Game of Thrones Samwell
tarly and is voiced by Weird Al Star
Daniel Radcliffe if you haven't seen a
red Game of Thrones Sam Charlie was a
part of the Night's Watch the Night's
Watch took thousand celibacy just not as
aggressively as his self-castrated
Knights of the sun like Dietrich Vader
before him Radcliffe is actually a fan
of Rick and Morty and has apparently
been sought after for a role on the
series in the past Justin Roiland
actually suggested him to play Young
Morty in those live action shorts but
obviously Radcliffe was way too old for
the part unfortunately nortenio learns
that in order to become a knight you
have to cut your own peanut are off and
toss it into the sun this stumping of
the pump is a play on religious
circumcision but far more aggressive I
don't even want to look at these
artistic depictions of this happening
let alone hear about it don't do that
leave your dicks alone below those
horrifying images is a stained glass
wheel featuring images of all the Sun
Kings of the past luckily Rick shows up
just in time to help Morty Escape due to
his scientific prowess he can
comfortably walk around on the sun's
surface as if he were native to its fire
surprising the knights he hands his
grandson a sword that recently used its
AI combat analyzing algorithms to study
Wesley Snipes Blade films and Morty
easily defeats the Sun King in combat
becoming the sun's very first king with
an attached penis he bids the knights
farewell and basically tells them to
leave him alone when they get home
Rick's sword is still carrying out some
moves from Blade's fight against Deacon
Frost from 1998's blade a cup of good
coffee is like a cozy blanket and a mug
that goes in your tummy it's delicious
at any rate and Trade coffee can help
you up your coffee Game Trade coffee is
a coffee subscription service that makes
it so simple for you to discover new
coffees and make your best cup of coffee
at home every day no fancy equipment
required if you're a coffee person
you'll love Trade coffee trade partners
with the nation's top rated independent
roasters so you get great coffee while
supporting small local businesses a
win-win whether you already know what
you like or are new to Specialty coffee
and need some help trade makes being or
becoming a coffee person easy they'll
send you ground coffee or whole beans
for however you make your coffee at home
this month's trade sent me a few copies
including Bark at the Moon from drink
coffee do stuff in Lake Tahoe
I love it it's so good it's got notes of
chocolate caramel and toffee whether
you're just getting started or a coffee
Aficionado looking to discover something
new trade guarantees you'll love your
first bag or they'll send you a new one
for free upgrade your coffee today with
Trade coffee and let them take the
guesswork out of finding your perfect
cup treat yourself or the coffee lover
in your life with Trade coffee right now
trade is offering our listeners a total
of 30 off a subscription and access to
limited time holiday specials at
drinktrade.com new rockstars that's
dreamcreate.com new rockstars for thirty
dollars off your subscription to the
best coffees in the country Morty
doesn't understand why Rick is being so
normal to him after he a dragged his
grandpa to an annoying food stand be
refused to take his advice C took a
random sword from a guy who unalived
goodbye to himself C almost got his
Johnson sniffed off and D needed Rick's
intervention to get them both home
normally if something like this happened
Rick would be rubbing all of this in
Morty's face but instead he's showing
him Morty empathy and kindness season
six Rick is different over the course of
the Season we've seen him move away from
several of his toxic personality traits
like when he made the choice to finally
move on from Diane's debt allowing him
to be more present with his living
family he saves Morty from Royal life
well lived bonds with Jerry during Final
Destination and even takes on the piss
Master mantle after finally learning to
empathize and de-escalate here it seems
like he's trying to put more effort into
caring about Morty's feelings but Rick
seems to finally understand why Morty
didn't listen to him after countless
episodes of ragging on his grandson his
opinion just doesn't hold much weight
anymore he promises to be 22 percent
nicer to Morty for the rest of the
episode slash Adventure the knights
reappear roasting the neighbor's house
in the Smith's Garage they insist on
serving King mortaniel addressing Rick
as wizard Daniel Radcliffe's night
explains to the family that it's their
people's duty to protect the solar
scepter aka the device that acts as the
literal center of the solar system
around which every single planet orbits
actually Beth these Knights may not know
it but yes that's exactly what it
metaphorically does in hindsight the
scepter being protected by the Sun King
does prevent Jupiter Saturn and all the
other planets from bumping into each
other politically hearing how dumb the
nights sound Morty seizes the
opportunity to teach them some sixth
grade science destroying their belief
system and convincing them that the
scepter is merely a cultural artifact I
love how when Morty is lecturing the
knights Rick is off-screen collecting
their scepter instead of revealing the
scepter himself he kicks it over to Mori
in a box supporting Morty and giving him
the spotlight with its reveal
disillusioned and [ __ ] the night's
sleep defines him skag when this Knight
pulls out his phone he's actually not
Googling Despair and instead has pulled
up an episode of the history of New York
podcast about architecture Rick proudly
announces to the family that Morty used
critical thinking and basic physics to
destroy his first religion but as Morty
recounts the way he and his grandpa
learn to support each other better the
sun looms brightly and ominously in the
background behind them suddenly a solar
flare bursts from the Sun causing
Earth's Electronics to go Haywire IRL
the radiation from solar flares can
cause blackouts and radio signal
disruption the Knight played by Matt
King emerges from the bathroom and
learns that not only are the sons of the
Moon invading their City the other
Knights of the Sun have completely
disbanded while he was pooping and
political turmoil has erupted in the
solar system this outlines one of the
episode's core themes that Traditions
may be silly and incorrect but if
they're foundational to a society
removing them may cause numerous
unintended consequences Rick Morty and
the rest of the Smiths look down on the
knights for their beliefs not realizing
their beliefs do serve a solar
system-wide purpose in order to solve
the mess he's made Morty's gonna have to
understand the problem he's caused from
a human angle not a sciencey one to fix
this burgeoning interplanetary war Rick
and Morty head to an area of the Moon
labeled yield neutral zone this agreed
upon Gray Zone for diplomacy in the
solar system could be a reference to the
neutral zones in Star Trek in Star Trek
lore there's been both a Romulan
Federation neutral zone and a Klingon
Federation Zone which acted as buffers
between these Empires and the United
Federation of planets as Rick and Morty
approached the conference of planets
Morty's surprised that Rick doesn't know
more about the rest of their Galaxy he
responds that hanging out on Pluto is
Jerry League [ __ ] when he can be
visiting more interesting universes and
dimensions this is of course a callback
to season one Something Wicked This Way
Comes where Jerry became a prominent
scientific figurehead on Pluto when he
defended its claims of Planet Hood the
corrupt government of Pluto used its
false planetary status to con its people
into ignoring the environmental hazards
of mining plutonium which was shrinking
the planet as a result we don't see
scruby noobers or any other plutonians
in this episode so I wonder if this
shrinking crisis caused the collapse of
their society or has prevented them from
engaging with the solar war in some way
inside the negotiation tent
representatives for seven of the eight
planets in the Milky Way are present
with Uranus being Mia that said not all
parties in the Solar War present the
initial aggressors in this conflict the
sons of the Moon are absent as well
though we do see their
barbarian-inspired war parties later on
in the episode and this week's behind
the episode feature the crew of Rick and
Morty described that they wanted this
episode to feel like Morty was dropped
into season 6 of Game of Thrones without
time to comb through all its dense lore
we see this on full display in this
scene and Morty even comments that he's
not gonna read all the books a joke
about the length via Song of Ice and
Fire novels to break down the players in
the Solar War let's go in planetary
order first we have the representatives
of mercury who Don Greco-Roman style
armor you'll notice that the Mercurial
people all have one breast removed this
is a reference to the Amazon Warriors of
ancient Greece who are fabled to have
cut off their right breasts in order to
improve their archery the word Amazon
actually means without outer breast
interestingly Amazons were considered
Daughters of the warrior God Ares and
his Roman counterpart Mars not Mercury
next we have the vi counts of Venus
their leader lift doors voiced by Jack
Black who's the perfect cherrier on top
of this week's stacked guest star Sunday
these venusians are pretty goth which
sort of makes perfect sense Venus is the
most hostile planet in our solar system
with active volcanoes and a thick
sulfuric atmosphere it's actually hotter
than Mercury despite being further from
the Sun because of the conditions on
Venus's surface it's no wonder that its
inhabitants are indoor kids Venus also
rotates in the opposite direction of
most other planets and so slowly that
its days are longer than its ears so of
course it's the Hot Topic of planets
Earth's representative is named The Earl
of Earth and looks exactly like our
human interpretation of Santa Claus
although he has no idea who Santa is
when Morty refers to him as such with
his access to space-faring Tech it's
reasonable to assume that he could
travel the globe in one night so he's
likely the cultural inspiration for
Santa within Rick and Morty I wonder if
we'll actually get more of him in next
week Christmas episode next we have Mars
The Marquis of Mars and his people are
all dressed like John Carter of Mars the
protagonist in a series of novels by
Edgar Rice Burroughs that were later
turned into Comic and film adaptations
because Mars is a God of War each of
these martians are missing various Slims
and they're the quickest to declare war
Jupiter also Sports a Greco-Roman
aesthetic but instead of battle Garb
like Mercury they favor purple robes
Jupiter was the king of the Roman gods
and purple is the color associated with
royalty in ancient Greece and Rome the
leader of Jupiter calls the other
planets moons not only because of
Jupiter's massive size but also because
they have 80 known satellites three of
Jupiter's moons IO Europa and Ganymede
orbit in a pattern known as the LaPlace
resonance for every complete orbit the
Ganymede makes Europa makes exactly two
and IO makes exactly four it's a stretch
but the notable orbital Resonance of
these three moons might be the
inspiration for Jupiter's three-pointed
symbol and triangular motifs saturnal
people pretty obviously take pride in
their rings for which Saturn is known
they also make a mention of having all
the balls which might be a Sly reference
to Saturn having more moons than Jupiter
with 83 total their green and gold color
scheme aligns with mythological Saturn's
domains of Agriculture prosperity and
wealth the rest of their design draws
from Arabic cultures despite them using
Norse longships with Egyptian Jackal bow
Spritz this type of cultural mashup is
common in fantasy and sci-fi which makes
it all the more fitting for Game of
Thrones in space Neptune makes a brief
appearance and because Neptune is an
oceanic God this representative hits the
nail on the head by dressing like
Poseidon the last attendee of this
meeting is the witch with stitched up
eyes the concept of a blind Clairvoyant
old woman is another ancient Trope that
spans back to the graya or the gray
witches in Greek mythology that shared a
single eye after Morty effectively
starts solar War 1 over the scepter
Goodbye Blue Sky by Pink Floyd begins to
play this song seen in the wall depicted
the transition from times of Peace into
Times of War as Nazi Germany Rose to
power as well as the blitz bombing of
the UK while it plays in this episode we
see solar War 1 unfold history is quite
literally written in the blood of the
losers as the set is claimed by each
planet in the war for the solar Throne
it's interesting to note that the major
players in this conflict don't actually
die after being stabbed repeatedly we
even see a mercurian soldier recovering
from being stabbed in the chest later in
the Montage this night immortality seems
to be exactly what the Knights of the
sun claim to have so they might really
share an ancestor like Rick theorizes
the Earl of Earth is crucified on a
giant x a joke about Kris kringle's role
is in non-denominational Xmas figure see
kids this image is what happens when you
take the Christ out of Christmas Santa
dies
don't cry are you this Montage also
depicts how War propels scientific
breakthroughs Venus uses the new
technology they've discovered from
various parts of the solar system and
Saturn deploys mustard gas against Venus
a direct reference to the usage of
mustard gas in World War one as each
representative Falls their likeness is
added to the stained glass depiction of
previous Sun Kings one of the Martians
figures out how to 3D print himself a
new robot arm and while fighting over
the scepter one of the saturnians gives
the old Three Stooges poke to one of the
mercurians as the war rages on Earth is
taking quite a few blows and although
Morty asks Rick to jump universes like
they did after the squirrels took over
or when their Homeworld got Cronenberg
Rick insists that they follow through on
their commitment for a change Morty asks
him what is this fat of acid again
referencing the season 4 episode where
Rick pretended to support Morty and his
dumb ideas as an elaborate ruse to
punish him for dissing his favorite
Escape maneuver the vat of acid this
play involves hiding in a fake vat of
acid for potentially hours while the
coast clears that's valuable time that
Morty could use to do homework or jerk
off so he hates the time suck this
episode however inverts the original vat
of acid episode instead of humiliating
Morty and forcing him through cruel and
unusual pain for rejecting his advice
Rick earnestly wants his grandson to
find a solution for the consequences of
his decisions Morty accuses him of being
a clone or a robot because of his
behavior and Rick remarks that their
family are he has enough of those he's
referencing mechanical summer mechanical
Morty from season 3's rickmancing the
stone the decoy Smiths and the cloning
of Beth also the way Rick words this
makes me wonder if there is currently a
robot hiding amongst the Smiths Beth has
her clone space Beth and Jerry's
confirmed to be From Another Dimension
so I'm thinking that summer might be the
prime candidate for the next sci-fi
gimmick Morty ultimately decides that
their best course of action is to Simply
re-illusion the Knights of the Sun and
convince them to return to their posts
he finds the knights strung out on sweet
Black Betty her body's impervious to
overdosing on Mr Brownstone Morty offers
to cut off his schwang in exchange for
their return and Daniel Radcliffe's
night happily explained games that this
will be just as good as Dr Feelgood
itself all these euphemisms for heroin
are also rock songs Black Betty by Ram
Jam Mr Brownstone by guns and roses and
Dr Feelgood by Motley Crue at The
Stomping ceremony Morty's handed a big
old pair of rusty scissors this could
just be all the Greek mythology
references bouncing around in my Noggin
but I immediately thought of the Fate
scissors from Hercules when I saw these
bad boys I wonder if they got bent
trying to cut the thread of a demigod's
wang after getting his bonus dongs
intercepted by three layers of security
including this cute little green witch
dick Morty's faced with actually having
to give his knick-knack a solar thwack
luckily Rick is even prepared for this
exact scenario and uses a telepathic
satellite to instruct Morty to run when
they reach a dead end Rick and Morty
begrudgingly pull Rick's favorite Escape
Plan the vat of acid upon re-watch
knowing that the pair go the bad of acid
root this exchange is recontextualized
while these might seem like normal final
words before diving into some plasma
these two are both well aware that
they're resorting to the that trip
without the pressure of their lives
actually at stake Rick is honestly
telling his grandson that he loves him
and that he knows how much Morty hates
resorting to the vat he earnestly wishes
that this adventure would end with a
solution more agreeable to Morty's
sensibilities at the same time Morty
accepts that sometimes his grandfather
is simply correct and that the vatic
acid is the way to go contrast this
scene with the end of season 4's vat of
acid where Rick forces Morty to use the
vat while the results end up pretty much
the same Rick's less toxic approach is
actually the healthier move for their
relationship overall when the pair do
make their jump their poses are exactly
the same as their first season 4
dunkaroo into the Acid Bath this poses
immortalized by the Knights of the Sun
and stained glass and apparently they
also used a ladle to check that they
didn't Escape into a vat of fake Sun
ladles are the go-to acid vat
identifying Tech solar system-wise but
it looks like Rick and Morty forgot
their Ladle blasters this time around
that or they're opting out because Morty
is such a bad shot like his inspiration
Samwell tarly this Knight proves that he
is a bit of a historian and even if his
history isn't entirely accurate in the
post-credits tag we follow an alien
detective in a big Colombo coat as he
busts the hot dog shrimp trafficking
ring returning the wigglers to Sea
before they can be crisped dude should
have dressed like Elliot Stabler though
because there is no way Chris Maloney
would get scooped by a big dumb bird
follow me on Instagram and Twitter
Whitney puppy follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you